on va revenir sur les salles de shoot
aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser à un
sujet qui divise profondément les
français les salles de shoot lancée en
2016 à titre d'expérimentation
elles sont censées permettre de diminuer
les prises de drogue dans les rues tout
en mettant en garde les usagers contre
les injections à risque problème de
nombreux riverains dont michael qui est
là il est au bout de sa vie se disent
aujourd'hui excédé par les scènes qu'ils
vivent au quotidien et se plaignent
d'une dégradation de leur cadre de vie
alors en effet plusieurs d'entre eux en
contact ont constaté la présence de
toxicomanes se droguant sous leurs
fenêtres
devant leurs enfants ou rentrent parfois
carrément chez eux et c'est vrai que
michael riverains juste à côté d'une
salle de shoot où vous êtes au bout du
rouleau en tout cas on va pas peut-être
pas jusque là mais c'est vrai que l'on
subit beaucoup de difficultés donc on a
cette salle depuis 2016 dans le quartier
qui pour l'instant est censé être une
expérimentation dont combine c'est une
expérimentation sa plantation de six ans
que je serais un homme c'est pas mal
mais voilà c'est comme moi c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai c'est comme un mec de
delphine union à faire une expérience
passions ses 25 ans qui avec m et je
vais remercier hans ulrich d'être avec
nous adjointe à la mairie de paris en
charge de la santé publique mercian
parce qu'on a mais je le dis moi je n'ai
pas peur de lire j'ai pas toujours été
très tendre avec la mairie de paris
j'ai même été dur mais merci d'être là
quand même ce soir mais je suis surtout
dur quand je suis en voiture
et d'ailleurs je me suis mis au vélo et
terminer très bonne il est maintenant
maintenant pour faire 5 km dans paris
autant faire un paris montpellier très
gentil d'être venu et là c'est pas qu'on
en parlera pas de sport perd environ
vous êtes sur la santé santé voilà
d'ailleurs vous avez gardé votre masque
absolument
alors justement vous avez vu qu'en ce
moment où il ya une question est-ce
qu'il faut garder les masques ou
paraisse que vont peut-être pas dès à
l'extérieur voilà l'extérieur à
l'extérieur vous le mettez ou pas oui là
quand vous mettez tout le temps oui vous
vous êtes en rappelant vélos sauf en
défense en vélo vous êtes en vélo aussi
impressionnant tous les gens qui
travaillent à la mairie de paris sont
tombés aux mains quand vous arrivez par
motobécane
merci d'être là michael il est là ce
soir et c'est vrai que michael déjà
comment vous avez réagi quand vous avez
su qu'ils allaient avoir une salle de
shoot en bas de chez vous
personnellement j'ai appris deux
semaines avant fait ce que la salle
devait être implantée à la base au métro
à côté de métro la chapelle suivie par
celle de la sncf à l'époque dont les
riverains se sont se sont élevées contre
contre le projet est donc là la mairie
et les autorités compétentes ont dû
trouver un autre endroit et c'est vrai
que l'un locales adossées à l'hôpital
lariboisière était apparemment le mieux
placé qu'est ce que vous vivez
aujourd'hui racontez nous tout ce que je
vis aujourd'hui pas cessé d injection de
rue sous les fenêtres c'est déjà la fin
non je n'ai pas d'enfants mais bon quand
même c'est une tannée
voilà j'ai beaucoup de vidéo où on voit
des enfants passer à côté de personnes
qui s'injectent en pleine journée à 14h
à 15h 16h 17h feintool toute la journée
des bagarres des cris des gens
alcoolisés qui sort de la salle qui
traînent autour de la salle il ya un
périmètre d'impunité entre guillemets de
tolérance on va dire qui a été créé
autour de cette salle par le procureur
de la république de 300 mètres donc qui
pour moi est une zone de non droit où la
police quand elle veut quand elle peut
intervenir le temps qu'elle arrive le
l'injection ou le deal cc fugace donc
c'est ça s'est fait tout de suite le
temps qu'ils arrivent là anne souyris
merci encore d'acclamer où je pense à
une chose moi imaginez vous avez fait
des économies faites propriétaire vous
habitez juston d'une salle de shoot
vous êtes propriétaire non mais ça pour
vous en rendez compte
la galère pour vendre l'appartement
après paris trois français sur quatre
qui vont mourir je n'achèterai pas la
presse par une salle de shoot en dessous
est ce que vous connaissez stalingrad
est à l'honneur alors stalingrad depuis
moi j'ai invité
il ya vingt ans de ça c'est vraiment
aussi j'étais voilà et bien il y avait
sept d'accord qui avait déjà usage de
drogue c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
pas un sujet nouveau métro tout ça voilà
comment moi j'en avais même sur mon
palier à moi et donc comme j'avais été
tout seul c'était pas hyper drôle non
plus donc c'est un sujet ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut continuer parisien ça
veut dire que c'est on partait de là on
partait d'un endroit d'un lieu d'une
scène ouverte qu'on appelle une scène
ouverte de drogue où il fallait faire
quelque chose et vous savez les usagers
qui sont du côté de gare du nord du côté
de stalingrad
tout à côté aussi de barbès on retrouve
aussi à porte de la chapelle
ce sont des grands stages et de drogue
des usagers de drogues qui sont des sdf
qui sont dans la drogue en général
depuis vingt ans au moins qui sont des
gens qui n'ont pas du tout envie
d'arrêter usage de drogue et pour
lesquelles il reste plus que ça donc
l'objectif c'est de les faire sortir de
cette de 7 de la rue et de l' usage mais
pour ça la seule chose possible
la seule chose possible c'est de les
accompagner de la wii sont si nous y
viendrons pas avec vous donc moi
en fait tous les toutes les méthodes
sont bonnes pour y arriver mais en tout
cas le côté simplement dispersion comme
on a pu voir à porte de la chapelle
comme on a pu voir à plusieurs reprises
depuis trente ans en fait depuis qui a
ses problèmes de drogue
sur cette scène ouverte eh bien on les
retrouve à ce qu' ils sont immenses a
fini devant lui de soigner juste ça fait
6 dans l'alimentation
quels sont les les aujourd'hui la
conclusion vous tirez est-ce que c'est
insultant mais pas justement on aille à
une étude de l'inserm non mais après
vous savez et à une étude qui on a fait
c'est pourquoi est ce que c'est une
expérimentation ces expérimentations
parce que justement l'objectif c'est de
se dire est ce que ça marche
est ce que ça marche pas et puis qu'est
ce qui marche qu'est ce qui marche pas
parce que c'est jamais blanc
complètement blanche à l'inserm dit une
étude de l'inserm vient de sortir il ya
quelques semaines avec sur les deux
salles de consommation puisqu'il en
existe une autre à strasbourg et elle
dit il ya 70% de moi d'overdose dans les
personnes qui vont dans cette salle de
consommation
c'est énorme il y a vous parlez de
tranquillité publique d'injection
public il y a deux tiers de moins de
seringue dans la rue alors moi ça ça
m'intéresse je donne ces deux chiffres
là pourquoi parce que c'est des chiffres
en termes de santé étant qu'ils étaient
publiques deux tiers de moins ça veut
dire que le reste un tiers
ouais non mais voilà donc ça veut dire
quand ils sont moins là mais qui sont
encore là et que comment on fait pour
encore améliorer ce processus et moi je
suis d'accord avec monsieur sur une
chose c'est quoi c'est qu'on doit le
faire toujours avec les riverains les
adoptions la montée comme ça il faut
encore plus le faire
ça n'a peut-être qu'on ne le fait pas
encore suffisamment aussi parce qu'on a
un comité de voisinage qui alors que
c'est pas réunies vous avez raison
en 2020 la pose du coc vide mais sinon
et c'est tout le temps est venu que j'y
suis allé à chacun moi donc je peux vous
dire est qu'ils étaient qui est très
important parce que vous savez c'est le
premier qui ont fait des salles de
consommation c'est les suisses c'est pas
des grands gauche et ses bas des hippies
c'était pas dans l'idée que tout le
monde allait faire la fête avec des
fleurs dans les rangs de la tête en
friche dans l'idée de récupérer la
tranquillité publique piste juste
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que avec l'aca
marché avec la crise du coc vide on a ça
l'a vraiment on parle beaucoup de cette
histoire de bénéfices risques là oui
j'ai envie de savoir aussi quel est le
bénéfice mais n'aura de ces salles de
shoot par rapport au mal qu'elles ont pu
faire valéry mézague vous vous dites
qu'il faut les fermer
oui parce que si je vous en vous entends
à tout à fait effectivement ces sujets
je suis extrêmement démago et sur le
papier je trouve ça formidable parce
qu'effectivement c'est une plus grosse
protection pour les personnes qui sont
drogués et qui évidemment comme je l ai
vu effectivement dans cette
dans ce sondage de l'inserm et ils ont
24 % de chances de faire de risque de
moi d'aller aux urgences de fer
d'overdose de transmettre le vih etc
pour autant je comprends monsieur parce
que moi je les grands discours c'est
formidable et c'est génial de 10 rue il
faut ouvrir parce qu'il faut protéger
ces gens qui sont dans la souffrance je
l'entends mais ça c'est un très joli
discours après - laver à titre personnel
je vais être tout à fait honnête si gdg
pas du tout envie d'avoir une salle de
shoot en bas de chez moi y compris si
j'ai un des enfants en bas âge parce que
j'aurais peur pour eux non mais moi je
suis très curieux et encore moins non
pas lorsque ses bénéfices risques et
c'est aussi surtout là
ouah du nombre combien il ya de
personnes qui vont aller pour faire déjà
un truc illégale et la france elle dit
ok nous on accepte ça mais dans quel
pays on est et à côté de ça
effectivement des gens qui ont économisé
toute leur vie et voient leur immobilier
et leurs biens chutent et en fait c'est
un scandale
à la rigueur qu'on utilise cet argent de
ceux de sept salles de shoot pour les
réintroduire ces gens là pour leur
donner d autres alternatives mais pas
pour leur dire tranquille là tu peut
confortablement continue à te juge et
tous ces enfants qui bien que c'est quoi
comme jeunesse qui va d'abord tant que
riverains on n'est pas content on
n'était pas contre le projet de la salle
on aime on est d'accord que accompagnés
entre guillemets accompagné
sanitairement des gens pour faire ce
qu'ils ont à faire dans cette salle on
n'est pas contre nous ce qu'ont dénoncé
une 70 très c'est que la mairie
enfin les autorités compétentes et la
mairie parce qu'il faut dire c'est
l'initiative aussi de la mairie et en
fait on pour abandonner quartier on
aurait dit oui à la rigueur s'il y avait
eu la police en permanence mais des
équipes de ces critères en permanence la
police comme il dit alors ne vient pas
parce qu'en fait longtemps qu'on les
appelle c'est terminé il ya eu il ya eu
aucune est la seule étude d'impact qui a
eu dans le fameux bilan donné samedi par
madame marie roustît il me semble qu'ils
aient pro salles de shoot julie salles
de shoot
le bilan est totalement orientée pour
nous on le sait avant on avait des
drogués à gérer on le savait en achetant
dans le quartier mais il ya il ya trois
cents 300 à 400 passages par jour
imaginez un peu le flux que sera la
bonne alors il ya un côté revendiqué
dans les salles de shoot qui me gêne
beaucoup
parce qu'on peut le faire tranquillement
bien sûr si c'est encadré c'est
merveilleux mais moi j'ai vu des
expériences ensuite de salles de shoot
qui ont dû être avec des moyens autres
qu'en france et conduit est fermée parce
que c'était des échecs faut admettre
aussi que des salles de shoot peuvent
être des essais d échec absolu en plus
de provoquer des nuisances
j'ai pour moi madame c'est un double
échec échec parce que ça ne règle rien
sur le fond et ça s'appelle un lieu de
fixation donc on fixe le problème de la
drogue en un lieu clos une salle de
shoot ou un jardin près stalingrad et on
ne règle pas c'est une manière pour moi
de se défausser de vous et des pouvoirs
publics de ne pas régler le problème de
la prise de drogue et la toxicomanie
mais de dire on va aller parquet donc
c'est déshumanisant et c'est invivable
pour le voisin
je vais quand même je voudrais quand
même dire deux choses 1 vous mélangez
spatiale en ce moment et la salle de
consommation les hall c'est une autre
histoire
honnêtement c'est une autre histoire
c'est des usagers de crack qui ne sont
pas pris en charge par la salle de
transformation est effectivement vous
avez complètement raison
il ya un vrai pro bahn de prendre de
prise en charge est justement moi je
vous redis je pense qu'une salle de
consommation permettrait non pas de
trouver d'être une solution mais d'avoir
pour les cracks heures pour les usagers
de crack permettrait de commencer à les
faire rentrer dans le soin parce que
vous savez on peut je sais plus qui
disent et là tout à l'heure que hossa
avait fait baisser le prix de
l'immobilier dans ces quartiers mais
c'est complètement faux with n'a pas
cessé il n'a ça c'est à côté moi côté
matières la longue course à côté des
noms 30 mai mais vous savez on a les
parents d'élèves avec nous vous avez
deux ou trois personnes aux mains des
deux rives ont méconnu mais il est
coincé mais les peuples ont des lèvres
si la connexion aux riverains content de
se passe comment se dire ça je ne me
fais moi je vous dis j'ai pas de
religion sur cette question là c'est ça
ne marchait pas et madame si ça ne
marchait pas on le ferme on a cédé 0,40
à jour les questions sur ces questions
là pour contrôler grande usa chez si on
ne commence pas par ça ça veut pas dire
faire que ça ça veut dire juste les
accompagnent et puis après laisser
partir ça veut dire que c'est cet
accompagnement la de la consommation
elle permet de commencer à prendre en
charge socialement c'est des gens qui en
général n'ont pas là si ce n'est plus la
sécurité de ses agents dont trois boules
mais basa donc c'est une manière de
rentrer dans le champ parce que j'ose
pas autant les les ont pas simplement
des gens que vous enverrez jeunes gens
tapent à vous occuper des drogués salle
hors sac contenant la mise à paris assez
d'endroits c'est pas un nouvel impact
mais qui est-ce qui veut d'une salle de
consommation en eau ris maintenant dans
paris je vous envie de rien à côté de sa
vérité non celle de saison marche bien
voilà un excédent commercial a fait le
tour des salles de shoot 1 par en bas de
chez vous bien évidemment mais je suis
pour les salles de shoot presque au
départ non au départ c'était fait pour
identifier isolées et soignées
c'était ça le départ est simple je vous
dis que c'était plutôt pas mal d'avoir
des endroits comme ça où les gens
pouvaient se faire reconnaître
maintenant le problème aujourd'hui c'est
qu'ils entretiennent c'est un peu faux
cul le truc il entretient le truc qu'ils
attendent en soi qui meurt soit qu'ils
partent
mais il n'y a aucune solution car ça
donne c'est que s'agissant de ce sont
les quartiers vous pouvez même espagne
avec des enfances à ses réseaux dans les
allées des mecs sont d'une violence rare
si freiner ces aides sont donnés sur la
question de qui et après qu'est ce qu'on
fait après une fois qu'on a réussi a
commencé à les prendre en charge
à avoir des gens qui sont une fois
qu'ils ont une prise en charge sociale
et sanitaire et comment ça allait se
faire soigner un certain nombre je crois
et donc vous avez des grands faire à des
grands toxicomanes donc ils vont porter
des vêtements sur ce break et en
revanche l'objectif c'est de diminuer
progressivement et de faire en sorte
qu'ils sortent de la rue qui sont
hébergés d'urines à monter 440 avait
encore c'est un panier pour dormir à
l'épaule et pour les hébergements et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est aussi utile
pour les recalés par des excès dans mon
quartier si je peux me permettre dans
nos valeurs c'est dans deux quartiers
qui sacrifie père dans ce paris est une
ville très dur c'est vrai pourquoi moi
pendant le premier confinement dans des
quartiers populaires comme ça il ya
plein de monde parce que cette scène
ouverte elle qui existent de cumin elle
a été fixée par les autorités
n'a pas été fixé là je peux vous assurer
que non parce que ce qui s'est passé
parce que moi j'ai vu progressivement je
travaillais pas mal sur sept ce sujet
vous savez depuis longtemps et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé on les a par exemple à
stan gradés ont été là et ils ont été
évacuées et son roman tebar babès puis
ensuite ils ont été vers la porte de la
chapelle peut ensuite y sont revenus
comme ils sont évacués chaque foyer
reviennent vers saint grat pourquoi ils
tournent toujours vers ces quartiers là
enfin parce que on les fixe là mais
parce que mais parce que pourquoi parce
qu'il ya un trafic de drogue et amélie
qui existe toujours oui non je vous
laisse j'ai reçu c'est que c'est une
zone de non droit sais tu nous ça ne
doit jamais l'être et même dans cette
expérimentation tu abandonnes disais moi
je la rejette dans l'arrêté doit être
quelque chose ne revient pas on n'a pas
vu des gens m'avaient des gens de cette
salle qui cherche c'est ça ne doit pas
la distribuer des kits d'injection et je
suis descendu pour aller hurler sur ces
gens de cette salle je sais pas qui
étaient des animateurs etc qui donnait
les quittent parce qu'ils étaient
débordés et croyez moi pendant
confinement croyez plus personne dans
les rues on a vu les gens ils leur
disaient allez vous piquez plus loin
donc dans nos rues en face j'ai des
photos par dizaines les collectifs de
rêvant d'être par dizaines
on a été abandonnée moi je sortais de
chez moi je me faisais contrôle et
l'attestation j'ai demandé à messieurs
les policiers et fait pourquoi ces gens
là ne sont pas contrôlés ils avaient
ordre de ne pas le comtal le confiant
voyez où on en est c'est l'offre
d'accord pour travailler avec vous si
vous nous mettez la sécurité si on
travaille en suisse lui
moi je suis pour qu'ils aient des salles
de shoot enfin si si il ya des gens qui
ont la volonté de s'en sortir il faut
bien quelqu'un d accompagner après je
suis d'accord que le quartier est
peut-être mal choisie par des médias
comme elle vient des lieux dans la ville
de paris ou alors voilà on peut on peut
tout et d'anvers avec ça se passe bien
et est peut-être cet outil n'est pas
adapté madame nan mais peut-être que la
salle est peut-être trop petit peut-être
enfin visite à paris
plusieurs équipes se trouve ça honteux
d'utiliser de l'argent public pour
ouvrir des salles qui permettent aux
gens de se droguer de manière encadrée
de manière modérée ça envoie un signal
désastreux qui est que beau final la
drogue c'est toléré c'est pas si grave
que pour arrêter là je suis désolé pour
moi la solution contre la drogue quand
même plus beaucoup d' addiction c'est le
sauvera la totale c'est dramatique au
réseau à sevrey fait les chambres sont
pas d'âge comment passer un terrible se
droguer ou pas faux pas on autorise
quand même pas comment faire pour ce
sera totale c'est horrible